i
estar un mes en cerrado no fue sencillo
elige tres personas que puedan pasar a
visitarte 3 seguro hay más personas que
quisiera ver digo ok no muchas más pero
seguro más de tres
los demás podrán verte a través de un
vidrio y hablaras con ellos por medio de
un teléfono
si me hubieran dicho que se iba a tratar
únicamente de ese mes encerrado lo
hubiera firmado desde el principio
pero no era únicamente ese mes sino
todos los años anteriores los que ya me
tenían francamente cansado
cuando tú sabes que vas a estar
encerrado un mes lo mejor es planear tus
actividades aunque sea a grandes rasgos
30 días parecen pocos pero en la soledad
y el encierro cada segundo cuenta
a decir verdad por momentos me sentía
orgulloso y desde los poquísimos que han
estado aquí sin volverse loco
ok y es verdad que por dentro y por
fuera aparentaba estar en una calma
absoluta como si mi mente todo estuviera
bajo control
pero sólo quería salir corriendo de ahí
tener una vida normal
quería poder olvidarme de todo
pero uno no puede olvidar quién es uno
no debe olvidar el camino recorrido
porque entonces uno podría volver a
vivir algo que ya no era necesario vivir
cuando tenía 18 años me diagnosticaron
una enfermedad llamada linfoma de
hodgkin cáncer me dieron quimio si
radios y quedé en remisión esto quiere
decir que la enfermedad no se
manifestaba más cuando tenía 22 años
recién cumplidos me dijeron que había
recaído esta vez el tratamiento en un
poco diferente debía llevar primero
durante unos meses una serie de
quimioterapias un poco más fuertes luego
descansar un mes y finalmente pasar un
mes encerrado y aislado en la unidad de
trasplante de un hospital para la última
parte del tratamiento un autotrasplante
de médula ósea básicamente consiste en
recibir una dosis extrema de
quimioterapia que te deja con menos
defensas que un bebé por eso debes de
estar aislado y luego recibes tu propia
sac para empezar a recuperarte
como que me lo contaron como quien al no
no no me late tanto no me parece tan
simpáticos de tratamiento y me negué a
hacerme el tratamiento y tenía mis
razones
la primera vez que me detectaron yo me
sentía de maravilla porque la enfermedad
estaba en una etapa inicial
el tratamiento fue duro y aunque no la
pasé tan mal el malestar no fue nada
agradable así que mi mente lo procesó de
este modo yo estaba bien el tratamiento
me puso mal
la segunda vez que me detectaron yo me
sentía bien porque la recaída estaba en
una etapa inicial y pensé yo no voy a
permitir que un tratamiento me vuelva a
poner tan mal
y tenía otra razón
estaba estudiando y quería poder acabar
mis estudios antes de hacerme cualquier
tratamiento me faltaba menos de un año
así que yo pensé bueno que más de
esperar unos cuantos meses
la realidad es que puse a mi carrera
por encima de mi salud
estudié teatro y yo pensaba no es que el
teatro es sagrado
nada nada puede interrumpirlo ni
siquiera un cáncer y así lo hice
y acabé mis estudios con los máximos
honores académicos sin hacerme el
tratamiento
y también en estos diez meses acabe con
mi salud
yo estaba convencido de que yo me podía
curar de otros modos métodos
alternativos y debo decir que no tengo
nada contra ellos simplemente ninguno de
ellos funciona en mí y claro decía yo
estar seguro del poder de mi mente para
curarme
yo estoy convencido de que la enfermedad
es una elección
es una forma de ver la vida es una forma
de enfocar la realidad de una forma de
relacionarme con la realidad y la salud
también lo es y yo pensaba que
compararme frente al espejo y decir
escojo la salud todo estaba hecho como
les decía aparentaba una calma interior
y exterior y decía que no había nada más
poderoso que la mente y es verdad no hay
nada más poderoso que la mente pero
precisamente por eso yo tenía que vivir
las consecuencias de la elección de esa
mente y como mi elección también era
seguir viviendo
no me podía seguir peleando con la
medicina
pararme en frente al espejo y decir
escojo la salud mientras me niego a
hacerme el tratamiento
bueno pues parece un poco contradictorio
decidió un día medianoche que ya no
aguantaba más
no podía dormir porque sentía que un
cuchillo me estaba atravesando el
abdomen y apenas si podía respirar
así que llegué de urgencia al hospital
en la madrugada y lo que un año antes
cuando decidí no hacerme el tratamiento
era una fase inicial se había convertido
un año después en un cáncer en fase 4 b
es decir muy muy avanzado
invadido por cuello vaso hígado pulmones
pregunte sobre mis probabilidades de
salir avante
primero pasa esta noche
me dijeron
y es que tenía un ganglio tan inflamado
cerca del corazón
que la probabilidad de infarto era alta
pero no estoy aquí para victimizarme
ni para dar lástima ni para causar una
falsa admiración el enfermo no tendría
por qué ser admirado al menos no por el
hecho de estar enfermo no somos
guerreros no libramos batallas nadie nos
mandó una batalla por ser los soldados
más fuertes dios no está jugando a ver
quién aguanta más el enfermo está donde
está por decisión propia
y yo estaba donde estaba por decisión
propia
permítanme compartirles tres razones por
las que yo veo al cáncer como un aliado
nunca he compartido el pensamiento de
ver al cáncer como un maldito puesto que
el cáncer no es algo externo al enfermo
el cáncer no es un enemigo el cáncer es
un aliado en la búsqueda del cambio y la
verdad los que hemos enfermado hemos
decidió aprender de ese modo lo que de
otra manera nos hubiese resultado
imposible aprender y no porque no
existan en formas menos dolorosas de
aprender
sino porque los que hemos enfermado
hemos elegido esta manera
el cáncer da la señal de que voy por el
camino equivocado
a un enemigo tal tipo de aviso que
ahorita ahondar en esta idea pero
yo les digo que la enfermedad demanda
ser escuchada para que el cambio de
percepción se dé si uno presta atención
y abre el diálogo con la enfermedad ésta
desaparece pues su función de ayuda y de
corrección se ha cumplido
para que me enferme no por qué
si no para qué
qué me quieres decir
querido cáncer con esto
por supuesto que al principio todas
estas preguntas me parecían lo más
ridículo del universo yo no estaba
abierto hacerme ninguna de estas
preguntas porque yo estaba seguro que el
cáncer era algo que de afuera había
venido a atacar mi interior luego
caí en la cuenta de que el cáncer era
una voz dentro de mí gritando por ayuda
no fue sino hasta que decidí escucharla
que realmente pude entender lo que debía
trabajar y sanar
si uno no abre el diálogo con la
enfermedad ni la más avanzada medicina
puede con ella y aquí es donde se
instalan muchas veces la trampa de estas
ideas soy culpable de haberme enfermado
no no no no soy culpable puesto que la
culpa es en el fondo un gran sentimiento
de soberbia que nace de la indignación
de no ser perfecto como pude yo haberme
enfermado no
soy responsable de cada paso que dado y
cada paso que dado me ha llevado hasta
donde estoy parado hoy
no es lo que uno dice no es lo que uno
decreta es lo que uno hace
uno siempre llega al lugar hacia donde
camino y también uno puede corregir ese
rumbo
la enfermedad cumple esa función de
aliada
número 2
la enfermedad me permitió replantear mi
postura ante los eventos de mi vida y
sólo tengo dedos me puedo hacer la
víctima o puedo asumir plena
responsabilidad de mi vida sin medias
tintas ya estoy enfermo la enfermedad no
va a desaparecer por magia o no va a
desaparecer por que decrete que soy luz
y salud porque a eso me refería hace un
rato si yo me abro a la posibilidad de
que la enfermedad venga con un
aprendizaje que no sea una maldición en
mi vida
entonces eso quiere decir que yo tengo
que abrir ese diálogo con lo que me está
sucediendo pero si yo decreto yo estoy
ignorando estoy ignorando lo que está
sucediendo decretar es ignorar es poner
las palabras por encima de la realidad
de las cosas
hay algo que atender atiende lo
el cáncer me ayudó
le pregunté con todo el dolor que
implica conocer la verdad sobre uno
mismo que quieres de mí que me pides que
suelte
lo primero es aceptar que toda situación
aparentemente negativa en mi vida tiene
una ganancia oculta y esta ganancia
oculta casi siempre está relacionada con
contarme una historia sobre quién soy e
irónicamente muchas veces contarle una
historia sufriente me ayuda para no
tener que tomar responsabilidad y no
tenerme que mover del lugar en el que
estoy parado
soy capaz de admitir que la enfermedad
me hace parecer especial frente a los
demás ganancia oculta soy capaz de
admitir que de hecho la enfermedad es lo
que me permite estar hoy aquí parado
otra ganancia oculta
soy capaz de admitir que la enfermedad
nace me da permiso de tener actitudes
negativas frente a los demás sin que
nadie me lo pueda reclamar y que estar
enfermos es una forma de reclamarle al
mundo miren lo que han hecho de mí
desgraciados pero el problema es que
este juicio implacable que estaba
ejerciendo contra el mundo en el mismo
juicio implacable que estaba ejerciendo
en realmente en mi contra y se volvía un
círculo vicioso porque también me
juzgaba por haber sido débil y enfermar
ahora bien como toda idea tiene su lado
peligroso pensar que está prohibido
sentirse mal uno tiene derecho a
sentirse mal hacerme la víctima es otra
cosa es quedarme ahí estático sin
moverme
pero tenemos un problema con el
pensamiento positivo pensar positivo no
nos tiene exentos ni de dolores ni de
enfermedades vivimos en un mundo que
intenta condenar el dolor cuando es un
sentimiento sumamente necesario
estás triste porque acabas de terminar
una relación no nos es negativo 20
vámonos de compras no había inspírate
el dolor llega como las enfermedades
para avisarnos que hay algo que atender
atiende el dolor que te provoca el
rompimiento amoroso y luego te vas de
compras si quieres pero permite que las
cosas te toquen que las cosas te duelan
eres humano las cosas suelen una
enfermedad duele
una relación que termina duele un golpe
en la rodilla duele pero si atendemos el
golpe en la rodilla sin decir me voy a
ir de compras y se me va a desaparecer
el raspón
y ahorita voy a decretar y se va a
desvanecer mágicamente el raspón
no veo por qué tendríamos que adoptar
esta misma actitud evasiva que solemos
llamar pensamiento positivo frente a las
demás cuestiones de nuestra vida
número 3
la enfermedad me permitió conocer más
profundamente y dejar de querer
complacer a los demás y esto es muy
simple o sea cuando yo estaba en el
hospital y yo no sabía hacia el día
siguiente iba a estar vivo me pregunté
que he hecho de mi vida lo que he hecho
hasta ahorita
ha sido porque yo quería hacerlo
porque yo me conocí y porque quise serme
fiel y leal o porque quise darle gusto a
alguien más
y la respuesta debo admitir que se
parecía un poquito más a la segunda y me
dije a mí mismo es que de qué va a
servir que yo me haya pasado la vida
tratando de complacer a no sé quién
si de todas maneras mañana ya no voy a
estar aquí probablemente a quién les
sirve a mí no a esa persona tampoco
entonces a este mundo hemos venido a
descubrir quiénes somos no a ser
perfectos y para descubrir quiénes somos
debemos dejar morir al yo ideal es decir
a este personaje que se presenta bajo
diversas formas pero no importa la forma
que adopte por ejemplo no es que yo soy
perfecto no no eres perfecto sabes que
yo soy intachable por favor ni ser que
estás de ser intachable no es que soy
incapaz no tampoco eres incapaz
el grano de trigo que cae a la tierra
debe morir para dar fruto abundante de
lo contrario quedará solo y morirá
esta frase se refiere justo a esta idea
si uno va por la vida haciendo malabares
para mantener está máscara intacta
entonces no estará justamente dejando
morir a ese personaje es decir a ese
grano de trigo que si muere puede dar
fruto
estaremos como muertos en vida nunca
daremos fruto abundante porque pasaremos
la vida tratando de complacer a alguien
más y saben que nunca nunca podemos
complacer a los demás yo me di chance me
permití no querer ser perfecto dejé de
querer complacer a todos los demás
incluido y sobre todo a mí mismo ya mis
supuestas ideas de perfección me dejé
estar más en paz sin esa voz que a veces
todavía me habla diciéndome que si no
soy lo mejor soy lo peor
todavía tengo muchísimo por aprender
también tengo muchísimo que soltar
todavía tengo que permitirme disfrutar
más profundamente los momentos de mi
vida todavía tengo que aprender a
reservar mis energías para las cosas
realmente importantes es decir para
aquellas fuerzas constructivas y no para
las destructivas toda mi vida será
intenso y me aceptó como tal pero mi
intensidad la quiero enfocar en aquello
que me aporte felicidad
y ahí voy
y voy a veces pero también a veces soy
todo lo contrario a lo que les estoy
diciendo aquí
el cáncer me permitió ver que las
situaciones dolorosas en nuestra vida
nos permiten elegir otro rumbo
nos permiten volvernos actores
responsables y no víctimas de nuestras
vivencias y nos abren una puerta para
conocernos más profundamente y ser
consecuentes con ese autoconocimiento
ver al cáncer como mi aliado fue lo que
me permitió curarme y estar hoy aquí
que si tengo miedo de volverme enfermar
sí muchas veces pero
de qué serviría a vivir prestando
atención al pasado
mejor vivo el presente que nunca sabemos
si estaremos por acá
un minuto más
o muchos años más muchas gracias
[Aplausos]